Papa John's Pizza founder John Schnatter  is apologizing for his use of a racial  slur shenana says while his comments  were taken out of context he understands  his words hurt people he stepped down as  chairman of Papa John's board this week  after Forbes magazine reported he used  the slur during media training exercises  while he says he's sorry Schneider tells  our Louisville affiliate WLKY the  company conducting the exercise tried to  blackmail Papa John's for six million  dollars yeah they tried to extort us and  we held firm and they took what I said  and they ran to Forbes and Forbes  printed it and it went and went viral on  Friday the University of Louisville  where Schnatter was a member of the  board removed the Papa John's name from  its football stadium